here are some cooking tips straight from  scp-5031's brand new cookbook quantum  cooking with the murder monster tip one  be sure to use all six of your arms for  ultimate cooking precision kitchen  knives are also no good be sure to use  your bladed tail for all cooking  activities tip 2 cook to music my  personal favorite is jethro tall but  ambient mixes of calm morning forests  will also do for getting you into that  perfect cooking zone tip 3 pick only the  best ingredients cooked rotisserie  chickens taste much better than  volleyballs i've learned this from  experience tip 4 the kitchen is a  special place if someone enters your  kitchen and refuses to respect your  rules cut them to pieces with your  bladed tail and turn them into a nice  goulash they'll be much better off that  way tip 5 more garlic powder is always a  good thing quantum cooking with the  murder monster by  scp-5031 is available at no good  retailers pre-order now